she is the brightest and most innovative
the best campaign strategist in the game
responsible for the greatest political
upset in history you're a fighter Ching
I'm giving you another shot at the title
it's a presidential campaign in South
America fragile democracy economy in
real trouble our candidate is considered
arrogant and out of touch with people's
lives how far you behind 28 points the
opposition has cited their own American
pet candy
Jane Bodine Pat so what are you doing
here I thought you retired or gave up or
something what happened to your hair so
you still got a great sense of humor
how many towns have you going against
candy three or four times how many times
has he beat you three or four times
we're gonna have to take risks in my
tracker every event that Rivera attends
every speech you tape it security beats
you up you are doing your job right get
that beating on tape wake up this is war
there's only one wrong in this only one
and that is losing levanta la mano is
the Abilene glace gracias
you should feel something during the
interview like you have some tears could
you just turn towards the camera whoa
look at him this is it
at least a candy now this sweater this
actually kind of matters Jane this
country could go under we're talking
about people's lives you like to pretend
you're not one of us if you fight with
monsters for too long you become a
monster
your neighborhood where you live
people won't get ahead what are you
going to do we are trying to save easels
lives these are the six
not gonna stand by and watch
falls apart this is no longer an
election this is a crisis
we were going to shoot the commercial
porfavor llamas this animal would leave
this to prosperity oh he killed himself
rather than being one of our commercials
which he focused on us
Anton